we've already seen how to think about
something like 64 to the one-third power
we saw that this is the exact same thing
as taking the cube root of 64. and
because we know that 4 times 4 times 4
or 4 to the third power is equal to 64.
if we're looking for the cube root of 64
we're looking for a number that that
number times that number times that same
number is going to be equal to 64. well
we know that number is 4 so this thing
right over here is going to be 4. now
we're going to think of slightly more
complex fractional exponents the the one
we see here has a 1 in the numerator now
we're going to see something different
so what i want to do is think about what
to the two-thirds to the two-thirds
power is
and here i'm going to use a property of
exponents that we'll study more later on
but this property of exponents is the
idea that let's say with a simple number
if i raise something to the third power
and then i were to raise that to say the
fourth power this is going to be the
same thing as raising it to the 2 to the
3 times 4 power or 2 to the 12th power
which you could also write as
raising it to the fourth power
and then the third power all this is
saying is if i raise something to a
power and then raise that whole thing to
a power it's the same thing as
multiplying the two exponents this is
the same thing as two to the twelfth so
we could use that property here to say
well look two-thirds is the same thing
as one-third times two so we could go in
the other direction we could say hey
look well this is going to be the same
thing as 64 to the one-third power
and then that thing squared notice i'm
raising something to a power and then
raising that to a power if i were to
multiply these two things i would get 64
to the two-thirds power
now why did i do this well we already
know what 64 to the one-third power is
we just calculated that that's equal to
four so we could say that this is equal
to and i'll write in that same yellow
color
this is equal to four
squared
this is equal to four squared which is
equal to sixteen
which is equal to 16. so 64 to 2 3 power
is equal to 16 the way i think of it let
me find the cube root of 64 which is 4
and then let me square it and that is
going to get me to 16.
now i'll give you an even hairier
problem and i encourage you to try this
one on your own before i before i work
through it so we're going to work with 8
over 27
8 over 27 and we're going to raise this
thing to the negative
to the negative and i'll try to color
code it negative 2 over
2 over 3 power to the negative
two-thirds power
i encourage you to pause this and try
this you're on your own
well the first thing i do whenever i see
a negative exponent is to say well how
can i get rid of that negative exponent
and i just remind myself well the
negative exponent really just says take
the reciprocal of this to the positive
exponent so this is going to be equal to
the reciprocal of this is 27 i'm using a
different color let me use that light
move color so this is going to be equal
to 27 over 8
over 8. i just took the reciprocal of
this right over here
it's equal to 27 over 8 to the positive
two-thirds power to the positive
two-thirds power so notice all i did got
rid of the exponent and took the
reciprocal of the base right over here
eight over 27 is the base negative
two-thirds is the exponent
now how can we handle this
well we've already seen that if i have a
new a numerator to some power over a
denominator some power and this is
another very powerful exponent property
this is going to be the exact same thing
as raising 27
to the two thirds power
to the two
over third over three power
over
eight to the two thirds power
this is another very powerful exponent
property notice if i have something
divided by something and i'm bringing
the whole thing to a power i can
essentially raise the numerator to that
power over the denominator raised to
that power now let's think about what
this is
well just like we saw before this is
going to be the same thing this is going
to be the same thing as 27
to the one third power
27 to the one-third power and then that
squared
and then that squared because one-third
times two is two-thirds so i'm gonna
raise 27 to the one-third power and then
square whatever that is and that is
going to be over
all this color coding is making this
just switch a lot of colors this is
going to be over eight to the one third
power
eight to the one third power
to the
and then that's going to be raised to
the second power same thing we're doing
in the denominator we raise 8 to the
one-third and then square that so what's
this going to be well 27 to the
one-third power 27 to the one-third
power is the cube root of 27. it's some
number that number times that same
number times that same number is going
to be equal to 27. well it might jump
out at you already that 3 to the third
is equal to 27 or that 27 to the
one-third is equal to 3. so the
numerator we're going to be we're going
to end up with 3 squared
and then in the denominator
we are going to end up with well what's
eight to the one third power well two
times two times two is eight
so this is eight to the one third is two
and then we are going to
and then let me do that same orange
color eight to the one third is two
and then we're going to square that
so this is going to simplify to three
squared over two squared which is just
going to be equal to
nine over four so if you just break it
down step by step it actually is not too
not too daunting